what's up everybody welcome back to my
youtube channel richard on data if this
is your first time here my name is
richard and this is the channel where we
talk about all things data
data science statistics and programming
subscribe for all kinds of content just
like this
and hit the notification bell so youtube
notifies you whenever i upload a video
so by popular demand i'm gonna come back
today and revisit a really good friend
of mine
and i'm talking of course about julia a
while ago i did a video on the top 10
r packages you should learn in 2020 and
i really stress that it works like a
pareto sort of principle
that is about 20 percent or even less
than that
of all the packages that are out there
in the r ecosystem
should get you 80 percent or more of the
results that you need to do data science
work
well i got some comments asking me how
to get into julia
so i thought you know what the same
exact principle applies here
obviously julia is a general purpose
programming language and there are tons
of people
who use it who have all kinds of
different interests i'm mainly targeting
people here who are brand new to julia
and their interest is in data science
meaning their primary interests are in
things like wrangling and manipulating
your data
making easy to use powerful clean
looking graphs
creating models whether they're of the
statistical or machine learning or deep
learning variety
and then possibly creating reports julia
is fantastic for a lot of other things
like mathematical optimization for
example
but quite frankly a lot of those things
are not my area of expertise
and if things like that are your
interest a number of these packages are
still going to be very useful
but you're probably going to need to
supplement them with some others
so i'm going to go over 10 julia
packages that will help you conquer the
data science world from beginning to end
and they're all relatively popular
packages meaning they're all pretty
likely to have pretty helpful user
communities
as well as to be around for a while and
to hopefully remain in development and
continue being improved over time
just as a disclaimer all of this
information is as of the time i'm
recording this video which is june 2020
keep in mind that julia does have pretty
rapid package development
there are tons of packages you may see
floating around out there which are now
discontinued
and who knows some of these in the
coming months or years
may be discontinued in the future too
but they're all super
helpful today as another point this is
just intended to give overview of these
packages
and every single one of these packages
could get their own video or even
multiple videos on them
if you guys are interested in seeing
follow-up tutorials on these packages
let me know in the comments and we'll
see what we can do so without further
ado
we're going to start this list off with
a simple one and that's i
julia this is a package which will
enable your use of jupiter notebooks
and for those of you who are unfamiliar
jupiter is basically an environment
where you can create documents which
contain everything in one location
your code your comments your
visualization all that
and on top of that you can output these
documents as htmls
mds pdfs or a bunch of different other
formats
and this is the preferred environment
that a lot of people in julia and python
like to do
all of their analysis in it's not always
my personal preference
but sometimes if i know that i'm going
to be creating a report eventually
anyway
sometimes it's easier to do all my work
inside of jupiter
because it just keeps my entire workflow
in one single environment
so here's the i julia documentation and
as soon as you start julia
you'll want to import the pkg package
that's just
julius package management system it's
quite straightforward
and there's really only a few key
functions you'll need to use out of that
but you do that you run pkg.ad i julia
and you get iglia added now at that
point you can run the function at the
bottom here which is notebook
and then it'll take you through the
installation of conda and the python and
jupiter distribution
assuming you haven't already installed
those things after that point you're
good to go
you can use jupiter notebooks all the
time if that's your working environment
of choice
or just generally use it every now and
then when you need the benefits that
jupiter has to offer
and there's more options that the ijulia
package provides like installing other
julia kernels
in particular there's one really helpful
one that gets rid of dependency warnings
whenever you run a chunk of jupiter code
so that's a pretty nice one
also i julia is compatible with jupiter
lab if you prefer that over the straight
jupiter notebooks
now that you're all set up with your
environment of choice moving on to
number two we have data frames
so this package is julia's answer to
pandas over in python
and the closest analog in r is probably
a combination of the deply
r and tidy r packages this package is
going to give us our core
data frame objects and it also has tons
of other super useful functionalities
like selecting columns
filtering rows sorting your data sets
creating new transformations of
variables joins
reshaping your data from long to wider
vice versa
all that good stuff you've got the data
frames type
which is the object type a lot of your
data sets are going to be in
at least initially and you can see from
the example up top
that you can create a data frame
manually or alternatively
you can use the csv package and you can
read in csvs
and there's similar functionality if you
use sas data sets or anything else
here again in this first example you see
the select function up top which
you can use for dropping columns and
obviously you have similar methods for
filtering rows
sorting your data frame creating new
variables
all that jazz then if you look down
below you can see the super helpful
describe
function which will return things like
the mean
min median max number of unique values
number of missing values and data type
you've also got any sql user's favorite
thing in the world which is joins
now as you can see here you've got inner
left right
outer anti-joins etc etc
and then i'm not going to go through all
of these here because i could easily
spend a whole video on the data frames
package
but if you look at the contents on the
left you've got functions that are
inspired by hadley wickham's
split apply combine approach in this
package
as well as some functions for reshaping
data that is going from wide to long
format or vice versa so obviously
data frames is going to be an absolute
must know for any data scientist that's
picking up julia
now moving on to number three we have
plots now this is a super basic
simple easy to use visualization package
for julia
it's pretty popular clocking in at 1020
people
starring it on github at the time that
i'm recording this video
and it's not my favorite overall julia
visualization package
but it does have some pretty useful
features which you'll see in a minute
here
basically the way to think of it is it's
an interpreter for various
other visualization libraries so as a
simplest possible example we have a line
plot where some x and y are defined
and by default if you make a graph like
this plots will assume you're making a
line plot
more on that in a second but here's the
cool thing like i mentioned earlier
plots supports various different back
ends aka
different background plotting libraries
now one that a lot of people
are familiar with in the data science
world is plotly
so in this example you can set the back
end to plotly
before calling the plot function and
then when you create the plot
you have that interactive quality that
you get from plotly
where you can drag your cursor over the
graph and get more exact information
plot is obviously customizable and in
the tutorial you can find things like
layouts
colors then under attributes you can
find
objects that you can create the various
arguments you can pass to plot
a lot of good stuff like that now one
thing that is worth understanding in
this documentation
is the concept of recipes now these
aren't anything too crazy
just extensions of the plots framework
but they do enable plots to perform
different plot commands
use different functions and handle
different data types
so in particular one package you want to
add with helpful recipes
is called stats plots it has some
separate documentation which i'll also
link to in the description of this video
but it is a perfect complement adding
more functionality to plots
now number four is another visualization
package
and that's the lesser known vega light
so remember a minute ago
under plots when i mentioned that wasn't
my favorite visualization package of
julia
well that distinction goes to vegalite
those of you who are more familiar with
julia
may notice there's one visualization
package that's pretty popular and i
haven't talked about
and that's gadfly well i happen to like
vega light more than gadfly
i think vega light has a bit more of a
higher learning curve
but ultimately at this time i do think
it's more flexible and more powerful
here's an example of vega light at work
so the key functionality
here is the julia macro at vl plot
and now in the tutorial they import a
data set from the package vega data sets
but you can obviously use a data frame
just like we saw earlier to kick off
this process too
now the vl plot function has a grammar
of graphics framework
meaning our core components here are
data objects
and a mapping system and then optionally
we can include whatever scales or
transforms or aesthetic features that we
need
in the very first line of this function
they specify the object to create
is bars and the next few lines they use
the transform argument to perform some
changes to the data that have already
been passed to the function
that's obviously optional then next they
specify
to separate genders by row put the sum
of a variable called
people on the y-axis call that
population
then on the x-axis there's the label age
and then colors are specified with the
hex code then you've got a visualization
that looks pretty nice
looks just like something you might
create an r with the ggplot2 function
using the
wrap function inside of that speaking of
r
at number five we have r call now for me
it was pretty tough
picking which one of r call or pi call
that i wanted to put on this list
one obviously helps you run r code from
julia the other python code from julia
but i went with r because it's made for
statisticians
whereas both julia and python are all
around general purpose programming
languages
my list my rules right so here's how you
get started with our call
you add our call just like you would any
other package
but you also need to set up your
environment variables to point to your
local installation of r
and the tutorial is very nice at walking
through how to do that if you're
unfamiliar
now if you don't do this our call will
probably get confused and not work
once you start using it the ability to
write our code is super easy and
powerful
you can do this either from the juno
rebel or from jupiter directly
but here's some examples the user uses
the macro
r followed by quotes in order to create
what's called
r objects see the example up top where
they use the classic
r norm function to sample from a
standard normal distribution
but then in the next example they create
a standard julia array
and then pass that using the dollar sign
symbol
into r code in order to run r's t-test
function
so r and julia work together smoothly
and effortlessly
now that we've talked about r a little
bit on that last one
moving on to number six we have
distributions
this is going to give us all the
functionalities of statistical
distributions
now if you're doing any kind of
simulation work or you work in applied
stats or
biostats type work these are going to be
absolutely critical
so up top here in the documentation
we've got setting the seed
that's for reproducibility purposes then
we've got the creation of a normal
distribution object
only two arguments to that you've got
your standard mu
and sigma then that object is sampled
from
using the rand function and stored in a
100 element array
called x now you can do whatever you
need with that
and distributions supports a ton of
different statistical distributions
binomial exponential uniform gamma
are some of the ones i've used the most
in applied statistics work off the top
of my head
but there's tons of others that are
supported sometimes too you need to find
the best
fitting theoretical distribution given
an empirical distribution
of data as well so that array created
earlier
called x is fitted to a best fitting
theoretical distribution here and it
comes in close to the true values
from that little sample we've got a mean
of 0.04
and a standard deviation of 1.12
cool stuff again critically important if
you want to do simulations or any kind
of biostats work
and number seven we have pretty tables
now for those of you who know
are think of the functionalities here as
analogous to the ones you get from the
knit r
and cable extra packages in r if you're
going to be making reports
or especially if you're going to be
publishing any kind of documentation or
research involving tables
pretty tables is going to be your friend
here's the quick start from the
documentation
you can use the pretty table function
and you've got nicely formatted tables
now if you're using notebooks these are
going to look much better than just
printing off the data frames as they
are and then these are incredibly
customizable
you can make these with an html backend
or a latex backend
and you can change the alignment you can
set the table to print
only rows satisfying particular
conditions
great stuff at the end of the day if
you're doing reports or documentation
it is important to make things look good
presentation does
matter and to that end pretty tables
will come in handy for you
now for the rest of these we're going to
move on to more model driven packages
and to kick those off at number eight we
have the glm package
and this is going to make all of your
linear and logistic regression needs
super easy you've got yourself a basic
linear regression here
set the seed for reproducibility
purposes as
is good practice most of the time you do
modeling efforts
and now in this example we're using a
continuous response called
y and a categorical predictor called x
which takes values one two three or four
now data frames can help you make the
categorical vector data type
but obviously if you don't want to have
your predictor be categorical
no need to do that all you have to do is
run an lm
function just like you would in r and
you've got your classic regression
output
now from the object that results there
are tons of methods you can use to
extract results
you can get the coefficient estimates
their standard errors
r squared the predicted values whatever
you need
then there's your glm function for most
people
all they'll need is the logit link which
provides a logistic regression
but you've still got a flexible function
that can support
other types of generalized linear models
after a while you'll forget you're not
programming an r
next up at number nine for those of you
who are python programmers
you're probably already familiar with
the scikit learn package
and how awesome it is for all things
machine learning related
well the julia implementation of
scikit-learn is
just as awesome now for the most part
it's going to work extremely similarly
to how it does in python
but there are some differences most
notably the fact the julia
implementation
includes its own new julia based methods
here we go so psychic learn can support
somewhere between 100 and 200 different
models
and those can be supervised learning
approaches like linear aggression
svms random forest neural networks
or unsupervised learning approaches like
clustering
pca etc but then scikit-learn
is also a one-stop shop for transforming
your data which
is often the most important step of all
it's also flexible
in the sense that it expects arrays
similar to the way python's
implementation does
but julia's version does have the
capability to support data frames as
well
so this is straightforward we use the at
sk import macro to pull in the logistic
regression model
then you can fit passing in your design
matrix and your response variable
and obviously scikit-learn has
capabilities for cross-validation
tuning hyper parameters and all that
good stuff out of the machine learning
universe
now i'm saving the most technically
complex package of all for last
those of you more familiar with julia
probably already know which one this is
going to be
and it's flux flux is a julia package
for all of your machine learning and
deep learning needs
and it's quite popular clocking in at
the julia package with the most
stargazers on github at least at the
time i'm making this video
and i genuinely do think as deep
learning picks up and more
organizations start doing it julia is
going to be a great platform for it
just because of its beautiful speed and
syntactical benefits
this one is challenging even to give a
brief overview for
just because there's so much going on to
it but here's just a brief teaser
for this one you have a tremendous
amount of flexibility with doing things
like defining your loss function
manually
as well as performing gradient descent
all of it using only a few lines of code
and this works nicely because flux's key
feature is taking gradients of other
julia code
for those of you less familiar gradient
means the derivative function
one thing i do recommend looking at for
starters with flux
is what's called the model zoo which is
just a repository of various features of
it
you've got convolutional neural networks
recurrent neural networks nlp models
lots of awesome stuff link for that will
be in the description too
all right so you've seen 10 packages in
julia that are going to give you
enormous power and tons of features
to tackle real world data science
problems
and deliver awesome reports or graphs or
models
this is by no means a full comprehensive
list of everything
you could possibly need in data science
using julia
but the beauty of julia is it is growing
and the capabilities are expanding daily
you can already see though with just a
few packages
you can do tons and tons so thanks for
watching this video
if you enjoyed it and you would like to
support my work the most helpful thing
that you could do for me would be to
share this video
otherwise at least consider smashing the
like button
and also let me know in the comments
down below what your favorite julia
package is
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data